sin mariana viaja durante un minuto a 5
metros por segundo hacia el sur cuánto
se habrá desplazado nosotros sabemos que
la velocidad es igual al desplazamiento
entre el tiempo aunque en realidad
debería ser el cambio en el tiempo a qué
se refiere si tenemos un cronómetro que
decía 0 minutos al iniciar al terminar
debe decir un minuto si el cronómetro
decía 5 minutos al inicio dirá 6 minutos
al termino así que eso es el cambio en
el tiempo aunque no pongo la delta
normalmente porque la variable t se usa
por convención así tal cual pero si
quiero hacer énfasis en que esto es el
cambio en el tiempo ya que en algún
momento verán esta delta bueno ahora lo
que vamos a hacer es multiplicar ambos
lados de esta actuación por el tiempo
estas tres se van y me va a quedar que
el desplazamiento es igual a la
velocidad
el tiempo aquí nos están dando el tiempo
nos dicen que es de 1 minuto este es el
tiempo o el cambio en el tiempo y esta
es la velocidad
esta es la velocidad y lo que nos están
preguntando es el desplazamiento por eso
es que trabajamos con esta fórmula para
dejar el desplazamiento como nuestra
incógnita bueno entonces quedamos que la
velocidad son 5 metros por segundo al
sur como es velocidad siempre tenemos
que indicar la dirección por eso es que
pongo al sur y el tiempo nos dicen que
es de 1
así que este desplazamiento es igual a 5
metros por segundo al sur por un minuto
aquí el problema es que las unidades son
diferentes no podemos cancelar minutos
con segundos y para arreglar esto
tenemos que transformar metros por
segundo a metros por minutos o convertir
el minuto a segundos para mí esto es más
sencillo convertir este minuto en
segundos y esto lo voy a conseguir
multiplicando esto por algo que tenga
segundos en el numerador y tenga minutos
un minuto en el denominador para
cancelar estos dos cuantos segundos
tiene un minuto
sabemos que hay 60 segundos en un minuto
estos minutos se van de hecho estos
segundos también se van con este de acá
y me queda 5 por 1 por 60 o lo que es lo
mismo 5 x
las unidades que me quedaron son metros
sus lo voy a escribir aquí abajo que
tengo más espacio que damos que el
desplazamiento nos resultó que es 5 por
60 es igual a 300 metros al sur tenemos
siempre que están indicando la dirección
cuando hablamos de vectores
y si nos hubieran preguntado solamente
por la distancia a la parte de escalar
la distancia sería solamente de 300
metros al sur nos indica la dirección
por lo que eso sería el vector y sólo
esta cantidad la magnitud sería la
distancia